being vulnerable requires
courage because to act like you're tough
and fine
and to put off all your problems
together one day you're gonna snap and
that that's gonna be weak and that's not
gonna be great
the hard stuff is to look inside
yourself and go
this is going to be really difficult but
it's the truth and to put it
out there and to make yourself
vulnerable not only does it
show that you are an incredibly strong
person that's done this brave thing
by confronting something that
uncomfortable but it makes you stronger
because then you don't have that thing
to be afraid of
so there is this fear-based perspective
that all of humanity by default has that
they're like i'm not going to talk about
it
i'm afraid to talk about these things i
shouldn't share this i don't want to be
a burden i don't want to be judged by
others when in reality
and i can say this is someone who's just
felt it myself it's the complete
opposite
yeah that's big i just think that that
message right there
is like maybe one of the most important
ones because everybody's looking for
relief right
everyone's looking for some relief some
joy
some uh exhale uh
some freedom uh and and and so
it's it's in that vulnerability they're
so scared to go there so it's like to
again kind of like therapy to normalize
the fact that right on the brink of that
vulnerability which
i love i think it was brene brown that
defined vulnerability as being
sharing not sharing things uh that are
like maybe something that people don't
know but sharing things that you're not
sure you're ready to say
because otherwise you're just telling a
story so if you share it's like that
moment when you get ready to say or do
something that's like i don't know those
that's the one you like gotta step right
into because that's something that is
actually vulnerability because you're
kind of not sure how it's gonna go
yeah otherwise you're just telling a
story that you just maybe haven't told
yet
mm-hmm and that's what i'm great at you
know my whole little uh
comedy clown career was me going like
here's a bunch of stuff i want to talk
about well what about that thing you
really don't want to talk about
not yet and yet when i got there it
happened and
as you said with solo therapy everyone i
know
and mental health conversations about it
it's come a long way even the last five
ten years ago because the perception of
it would be like oh you're on
anti-anxiety medication which is
completely normal it's completely fine
so many people are doing it
that's crazy pills or oh no this person
is taking a mental health day ooh
they're having a breakdown and it's like
that's that's all misinformation it's
not true
we need to have this so much better
educated and less toxic perspective
on this universal experience of what we
all have going on in our minds
and even when it comes to therapy people
think i'm not
completely having a breakdown my life
isn't a complete mess i don't think i'm
this walking talking traumatized person
i don't need therapy
every single human on earth needs
therapy
because when you talk and it doesn't
what it is and you're breaking it down
is
you're actually just being honest about
your thinking and feeling with someone
who's there to talk back to you
like me in the youtube comments or the
people giving me that perspective it's
just someone going like
okay i'm gonna tell you what you are and
what's happening is saying and you just
have these
profound realizations and i don't want
people to think
mental health books podcasts anything
about it it's not for me
because i'm not at that place yet it's
we are all at that place
all of the time you cannot see it as
something to cure
when you've already snapped it's
something that you need to prevent
by knowing this stuff and keeping
yourself healthy
and happy and afloat the whole time so
you're absolutely right with that
i would make if i was an evil dictator
that's actually not evil
i would just force every human on earth
to have an hour of therapy a week and
i'd be like no more war
it would be great i think you're
actually right call it therapy call it
meditation i don't give a crap what you
call it but like any
same thing a couple of like mindful
activities and things to face yourself
like because again the therapist is just
showing you
you uh which is like uh
traumatizing because you're like oh
that's me and then you're like also like
oh that's right i mean that's
um so what is the third part of the book
about
it goes all into that hard stuff so it's
like hey
therapy um yeah it's gonna be long it's
gonna be hard it may be hard to access
depending on where you are in the world
how much money you have this that and
the other because that's the whole thing
you know medication
love it for some people it's a privilege
that they can even be medicated to get
them through a tough time and it's that
thing where
here's the knowledge you got to apply it
to your own life
it's about looking in and trying to just
analyze how do you see
the world what are the experiences that
shaped you how do you react to your own
emotions
how do you react to other people what do
you expect
from situations in the present in the
future based on things that have
happened to you in the past
and trying to recognize these things and
go actually have i been taught lessons
about how the world works because of
something that happened to me as a child
or even something recently
and therefore i'm going forward with
these expectations that are actually
super destructive
and holding me back in life and this is
the kind of stuff that
it can take you years to just know who
you are to unpack something that may
have come from a past trauma which is
why
you know it's like okay well you know do
this when you when you're in the better
place and so much of it's just
your mindset if you think that you have
this fixed mindset that you are built a
certain way you can't change you expect
certain things
that's what your life's going to be it's
going to be the same if you go through
life with the mindset trying to grow
and challenge yourself and be open to
new perspectives and experiences
then not only might you surprise
yourself by what you find but you can
just have a completely different
perception of
failure and attempting something and
what's the point of doing anything at
all
and that for me was one of those light
bulb moments
where i was like yeah okay my mindset's
pretty terrible i kind of i manifest
negativity everywhere i go because i'm
putting it in front of me like i carry
on a stick if i
reframe my thoughts not to believe in
sunshine and roses
and that everything's always going to be
fine you can't be toxically positive by
just saying just believe and everything
will be fine
you need to be realistic but you need to
be optimistic
to give yourself hope and that positive
momentum
in order to see it because this is the
most difficult thing for me
as someone who's so cynical and has
dealt with self-hatred but if you
practice self-gratitude if you look
around at the world and be thankful for
the things that you have
if you allow yourself to be proud of
yourself
for the things that you're good at and
the things that you do that will
actually make you
better as a person as a friend in your
career
and it's tough for me you know as this
british guy i'm like no
don't let the positivity in oh it's
going to make me weak but actually
it's just the truth and it makes you
more efficient so you can struggle as
much as you want
but realistic optimism it's actually the
best way to go
well said are you i know that at the
beginning you were talking about your
you know your your humor being
self-deprecating humor that is kind of
like
hiding in plain sight hiding issues in
plain sight that you just don't really
want to deal with and you kind of
you know you steal someone's ability to
sort of go there because you called it
out first right you kind of like
okay can we go now um kind of thing to
the issues
so is there i'm curious like you're
writing a book and
and um you know is there a transition
for you uh with your career and the
things that you do that you're really
excited about
that have come on the heels of uh
you know the work that you've done and
the opportunities that you have now
and or is there some late level of like
look i have now disarmed all of the
jokes because people
know they're real or you know you know
like or
i've just healed so much i don't have as
much to
self-deprecate about so maybe is there
some kind of transition that's just
happening some kind of alchemy in your
own being because
of healing 100
comedy and tragedy it's that horseshoe
curve where eventually their butts touch
at the bottom because really something's
only funny
because it's wrong and therefore there's
a contrast and there's humor
and really every single joke there's a
but the joke and
for me that was that was always myself
and it's as i said only
only because i am an entertainer and
putting things out there and i'd meet
people after a show
and they'd go hey you did that thing
here's my reflection of it
did i realize there's there's another
step here because as much as i wanted to
keep it
professional and silly and just funny
and not go to that deep dark place
someone would tell me
whether you like it or not that
resonated it with me this way so that's
the power that you have
and really that's the power that all of
us have to share our stories and to
connect to other people
and as time went on definitely
because like the book it's not a comedy
book
it's a serious book about how to sort
your life out
i am here as the guy that is writing it
in a funny way
using myself as that you know punching
bag i'm like the mental health martyr
anything that you think i've got a great
example of how i wasn't doing that to
say
yes this will start the conversation by
making you feel less
weird if i can make that joke to open
the door to
break that barrier down for you and then
there's a truth behind that's fine
you talk about healing i'm not
completely healed i know
what my problems are and that's half of
the journey
like regardless of whether i wrote the
book regardless of whether i've been on
any journey
i i still need to still need to work on
the issues so i don't think i'm going to
be completely strapped for comedy
material for the rest of time
but i think joking about these things is
okay
as an icebreaker to start the
conversation and to most importantly
make people know that they're not alone
in their experience
because if someone's joking about
something you're like ah you can't joke
about depression be serious it's like
well at least this person is
acknowledging it and someone else is
seeing an example of someone else going
through that
what you can't do is just leave that
once you've shown a light on something
you go
okay and now the hard part um
is that why you're writing the book do
you feel oh
yeah feel like a colleague i mean it's
sort of or is it part of the therapy
i am writing the book because it's the
thing that i
wish i could have read 10 or 15 years
ago because i could have just written
a book of funny stories about dan's life
and that would be
easy for me and it would it would have
been fun it'd be a lot more
self-indulgent but i was like no
actually
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this for myself
in the present and i'm gonna do it for
all the people
like me that i know are out there that
maybe i can
they they might not have to go through
10 years of questioning and softening
and just
banging the head against the wall if we
just put it all out there
so i hope that you know if i can
give back in any way you talk about
what's going to make you feel proud in
life what makes you what are you most
proud of and for
me it's that no matter
what i like to self-doubt about or think
about the meaninglessness of the
universe even the lightest entertainment
that i've ever done
if it's made someone just feel better or
crack a smile
on a really bad day then that's like hey
i can't even deny that i've done
something good
and i need that i need i need
irrefutable proof that no matter what i
i cannot say no to it and it's just you
know at the end of the day
if all of this has been for something
sure
i'll allow myself to enjoy that feeling
because there's no time for altruism
here okay
we're not doing good things and then
trying to be all pious about it go no
if you're if you're a good person if you
do good things if you make the people in
your life
feel good and that makes you feel good
that's how things are supposed to be
that's it i i was just that was
literally the last thing i was going to
ask you what you're most proud of
and you just said it so thank you thank
you you
um you're this will be a really big deal
that you're
taking um this time and
opening yourself up more into more
vulnerability
um even if it's into just like a serious
space instead of being
funny right i think there's some level
of vulnerability of going
no i'm scared i know you said i'm
serious i could be right like
there's like something like ironically
i'm
quite stressed and anxious about this
book being out there because there's so
much of me in it
it feels like i'm like oh my am i really
about to put this out there into the
world but i you know just have to remind
myself of why and what it's for so
yeah hopefully it's a good idea thank
you well done oh
um uh so have you been to the states
very much
uh yeah yeah i'll go there for a while
you know i used to now i don't really
leave the house
but hopefully we'll all be highly
vaccinated soon it's all gonna be great
right right well i i was i was just
going to finish up like i lived in
england for a few years and i was going
to
oh amazing you know ask what your
favorite british meal is
i mean my favorite british meal is a
chicken tikka masala because the best
british food
is the food that the indian population
of the uk i mean come on
we know what british food is it's all
very beige and thankfully
uh the multiculturalism has really
helped us out a bit here
so yeah it's true i want to say thank
you to the italian family down the
street thank you for the good food
all right well enjoy your tikka masala
and um thank you so much and
congratulations and
um keep um keep facing yourself
and we'll keep showing you who you are
which is like a super
beautiful vulnerable wonderful hilarious
witty british man well thank you for
saying that because
i would literally never believe it thank
you for having me
as well on something that's that's so
inspiring and the fact that you use your
time to have all these conversations
it must really be so transformational
for so many people so i'm proud of you
as well
thank you thank you